foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
on Facebook and uncensored tonight labor
leader Sakia stammer tells his top team
the public doesn't care about woke
issues is he right spoiler alert I don't
think he is but we'll debate him
Lionel Messi is supposed to follow
Cristiano Ronaldo the Saudi Arabian a
deal worth reporting 522 million pounds
but are these goats trashing their
legacies by Sports washing a brutal
regime I don't think so but we'll debate
it
plus the once feared U.S Navy Seals
appointed drag queen as our ambassador
which forces be ferocious not fabulous
I'll ask the Navy SEAL who killed Bin
Laden
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening Fernando welcome to Piers Morgan
on census Takia starmo May well be the
next British prime minister label it as
a hearty lead in the polls after 13
years of Tory rule with three prime
ministers in one chaotic year recently
his path to power is clear but it still
has to prove he knows what matters to
the British people and today I believe
he made a massive miscalculation he's
reportedly briefed his top team to avoid
talking about social issues woke issues
because apparently the public doesn't
care about them
he couldn't be more wrong the public
does care and with good reason here's a
reminder of what Elon Musk says about
woke
it is a prevalent mind virus and um
arguably one of the biggest threats to
monetization you should explain why you
don't think it's hyperbole to say things
like it's pushing civilization towards
suicide first of all what is the walk
mind virus and if we don't deal with
this nothing else can get done tell me
why you think that
yeah so
um
I think we need to be very cautious
about any anything that is
anti-meritocratic
um and anything that is uh
that that results in the suppression of
a free speech
um so you know those are two of the
aspects of the work mind virus that I
think are very dangerous uh is that it's
often anti-mureaucratic you can't you
can't question things uh even the
questioning is bad
what are the richest and smartest men in
the history of this planet says that
something's literally threatening
civilization we should probably not just
dismiss it it's very easy to dismiss
this stuff as culture wars diversionary
tactics used by politicians so we get
mad about Society instead of their
mismanagement and there is something to
that I get it but make no mistake this
woke virus is real and it ruins people's
lives it means western societies being
policed by radical minority of people
with ultra Progressive views that would
seem completely insane at most family
dinner tables it means people are abused
shamed and vilified sometimes handed out
of their jobs for expressing a
dissenting opinion it means our heritage
and our culture are being constantly
ransacked from Roald Dahl's books to the
James Bond novels to avoid offending an
imaginary cult it means ordinary people
having to hesitate before using
perfectly normal words like woman or
Bonkers or mother because they've been
Brown beaten into thinking it'll cause
offense it means biological males can
destroy women in sport and gender
categories are being abolished at award
ceremonies resulting as we saw at the
Brits and no women getting a minute at
all it means we're smeared as
transphobic the thinking it start raving
mad that a male rapist can identify as a
woman to get a place in a woman's prison
and above all it means the rest of us
are made to feel like extremists for
saying well hang on a second this isn't
right I don't want to live in this world
if you question it you are the problem
you are the bad person you must be
canceled at the heart of this is freedom
of speech as Elon Musk said freedom of
expression and freedom of thought
without that there is no democracy
perhaps the real reason why secure
Starman doesn't want us to focus on
so-called work issues it's because of
the problem he's had in answering simple
questions
I don't think that
um discussing this issue in this way
helps anyone in the long run well for
99. I don't know nine percent of women
everything is a matter of biology and um
I'm very very supportive of that for the
vast majority of women this is all about
biology and of course they don't have a
penis we all know that
99.9 something percent of women
um it's all biological and it's very
straightforward what's that percentage
again
how many women have penises again it's
okay
so far this year I've interviewed the
prime ministers of Britain Israel
Australia I went to the Ukraine to
interview president zielinski and to be
former US president Donald Trump I've
interviewed other U.S presidential
candidates for 2024. the one person I've
not interviewed is secure Starman or any
of his senior Shadow cabinet ministers
what are they scared of a labor party is
based 2.8 miles away from the studio his
front benches have an open invitation to
come on to debate all of this stuff as
well as their plans for running the
country but so far they've repeatedly
rejected all invitations
if you want to run the country
they should really stop ducking
interviews because the last guy that ran
the country
he ducked into these let me take a
little reminder a trip down memory Elena
what Boris Johnson did when I tried to
get an interview with him
Mr Johnson what do you have
you have you're live on good morning did
you talk to businesses I'll be with you
in a second I'll be with you in a second
piece here
[Music]
right he's been taken inside into the
freezer he's gone into the fridge
[Laughter]
so far isn't it that was heroic work
he ran into a fridge to avoid he never
came out we never saw him again ran into
a fridge shut the door Boris Johnson a
coward ultimately just didn't want to
face tough questions I don't think
kirstan was a coward I don't think his
shadow cabinet
cowards for some reason they don't want
to come on and talk about this stuff and
now they say the public doesn't care
trust me the public cares
I'm joined by the author and broadcaster
Jenny Clem talk to these people that
came the can and talk to your presenter
Richard Tyson welcome to all of you a
lot of views here but let me start with
the politics of this game
because this is quite a bold statement
by Kirsten it follows the local
elections on the face of it a big win
for labor a big loss for the Tories but
most of the maths around it say that if
that was replicated in a general
election labor would have to form a
coalition which would not be ideal for
them so it's not a home run anyway
this issue of of wokery of all these
social issues of the culture wars
why has he decided that he's going to go
out and say none of it matters
I think this is two things I think this
is kirstama trying to assert some
Authority and project some confidence
which is why he keeps saying things like
we are on course to win the next general
election when you're right actually
these local election results don't show
that they show he could form the largest
party he could form a coalition but he's
definitely not on course to win the next
general election so I think a little bit
of it is about confidence he wants to
show I'm on top of it I'm not going to
be led by the agenda I'm going to lead
it but I think there's some fascinating
polling behind this because most people
now according to you gov do recognize
what woke means they know what woke
issues are they understand the
terminology they understand what it
means to them and I think one of the
things you said in your introduction
about Heritage and culture is really
important here because for a lot of
people they may not identify what
matters to them as a woke issue but it
is about their culture it's about their
Heritage it's about history and actually
they care deeply about those things now
if you frame these if you say would you
care more about cost of living Christ is
or the work issues given that Stark
choice I can imagine people say well
obviously right now the money but
actually it it goes a lot deeper than
that yeah it does and that's why I think
it's a really interesting political move
because I think he's wrong you know I
wanted to be Richie sunac and actually
more interestingly than that when I
asked him what's a woman he said an
adult human female and food Anthony
Albanese who's the Prime Minister of
Australia he's a progressive from the
left die art
and he said immediately an adult female
because in Australia which is a pretty
Progressive country now even in
Australia they've had this backlash now
to politicians not saying simple
biological facts like that so it's an
interesting play that starmer who's our
Albanese
has decided this is the way to go I
think what he what sarcastama feels he
needs to do everything about what he's
doing right now is in stages he's he's a
stages man you know the first stage was
the local elections proved we can do it
okay throw off the shackles of the left
wing of the party isolate Corbin die in
Abbott too okay fine that's the next
stage what trying to say that work
issues don't matter is about is trying
to neutralize a problem that he very
much still has to tackle and you saw in
those clips there from zakirama 99.9 of
people women don't have a penis well
that's problematic it's still not clear
enough for some people and actually
that's going to dog him through this
leadership campaign if as we expect some
in the conservative party intend very
much to put those particular issues
right and Richard I mean the problem is
going to have is that they're going to
bring up people like Rosie Duffield
another labor politicians who've been
really shamed and vilified oh for
defending basic biology completely and
what it shows is that actually he's
completely out of touch with his core
very social conservative Northern
heartlands that he has to win over big
time if he is going to get a majority
and he's nowhere near it and you know
for that constituency they know exactly
what a woman is and they also do not
want their children to be taught things
around gender questioning in primary in
the early years of secondary even Tom
Hanks today came out and said that he
refuses to read any books which have
been dragged into the modern Morality In
other words all this issues around Roald
Dahl and everything he won't read them
if ever disclaimer say we've changed
words and stuff he said I'm not going to
read it I loved that because he's in
Hollywood which is normally the wokest
place out there and I feel that woke
worm has really turned because most
people do not think that way this is a
small noisy minority of people who
genuinely think they have this
self-righteous belief that what they say
not only is the Right View but the only
view allowed but it's also a question of
actually strong principled leadership if
he doesn't have the courage and the
conviction to say exactly what a woman
is then actually it's women who fought
for equality for decades and for the
vote and for the vote who feel most
offended by this outrage and you know
the truth is the real winner in these
local elections was the not vote party
because the turnout was woefully low
yeah and I think many many women are
saying well just hang on I don't want to
find I want to find out who who knows
what let's go to the other woman on the
panel I assume you're identifying as a
woman I identify as a woman right what's
your view of this well I think Kirsten
is absolutely right because uh you know
we know that this the conservative
government deployed the queen of
anti-woke the self-proclaimed scourge of
the uh wokorati in much of their
campaigning in the run-up to the local
elections she brought up things like
Rotherham and Rochdale which are you
talking about right I wouldn't call her
the queen of Andy well she's the one who
complains about the tofu eating Guardian
reading wokarot she very much positions
herself and that wasn't why they did
badly in the locals no well I mean but
certainly the pitch that they were the
way they were pitching themselves was uh
as I saw let me just stop you there
because I saw a very interesting poll
that came out overnight about why people
had switched who voted Tori in 2019
while they switched to labor almost all
of them I mean like the top like 50 60
right we're saying reasons to do with
the conservative party just being in the
job too long doing a bad job
the woke stuff to me could be a real
problem for storms I think when you
can't if he's not fair I think when you
cast your vote you think is this
candidate going to improve my life and
improving my life will be in terms of
can I get a GPS appointment can I afford
to feed my kids can I put the the
electric on through my house that's why
people vote they don't vote about these
cultural issues and they might matter we
need to get much better at using
language accurately if I said to you
what's the woman what do you say I would
say peers a woman is an adult human
female I think most people do agree with
that and if I say to you given the way
this debate's now moved about uh trans
athletes and Sport what is your view of
that my view is that there are times
when sex has to Trump gender and when
you look at prisons when you look at
would you let any trans athletes compete
in in women's sport I personally don't
think they should until there's evidence
now would you have said that a year and
a half ago yes I would have and I have
said these things but there's an
assumption that you would say look after
all of one of one and I know I'm not I'm
not pigeonholing you but would you
describe yourself as Progressive left or
not I I have never used that word to
describe myself before but I think I
represent a lot of women who uh who
would call themselves left with just
kind of intro we've got some breaking
news from the United States very
interesting music Donald Trump has been
found not guilty of rape in a Civil
Trial for rape and defamation in New
York a hugely publicized case E.G
Carroll was suing the former president
alleging he raped in a Manhattan
department store nearly 30 years ago the
court however did find Donald Trump
sexually abused e Gene Carroll awarding
a two million dollars in compensatory
damages for battery we're looking at
live shots there so that is a
double-edged sword for Trump uh he
didn't testify on the court repeatedly
denied the allegations but it would say
aim that on the most serious charge of
the rape not guilty but of sexual abuse
he's been found guilty so we're going to
verify exactly what has gone down there
but what's your reaction to that Richard
um well I think as you say you've got to
verify exactly what has happened there
and if he's been found guilty of sexual
abuse I would expect him to appeal and
because that's his that's his nature
whenever he loses anything he keeps
fighting that would be my instinctive
reaction just based on that so we're
going to get more information on this
but he's he's been found not guilty of
rape but guilty of sexual assault and
defamation so that is I mean this is a
big moment for Trump because of course
he's running for president again the
election is November next year he's
already been indicted on a criminal
charge involving the hush money payments
to Stormy Daniels the porn star and now
this e Gene Kelly's been awarded uh
millions of dollars in Damages what do
you think this will do in terms of the
of the presidential race I think the
people who love Donald Trump will see
this as part of the narrative that he
always spends which is that the
establishment are out to get to him on
trumped-up charges even if it's been
found in a court of law he will be able
to spin this as a way of the
establishment trying to suppress him so
I don't think it will deter the people
who are determined to vote for him okay
it's an interesting one with Trump isn't
it because this kind of stuff if this
happened to a British politician that
would be the end of their careers but
then so would the indictment have been
if a British politician was indicted for
paying hush money payments to a porn
star that would be the end of their
career Trump has so far proved
remarkably Teflon to all this stuff but
this is a very serious blow you have to
assume to his presidential chances yeah
I mean I think look this is a civil
ruling right so it's a slightly
different catalog yeah it's not criminal
albeit not you know it I mean it is
incredibly serious that clearly in this
particular case they've also decided
that he did defame her by branding her a
liar jurors have decided that I mean it
is a legal setback for Donald Trump
there is no doubt about it but Piers you
know better than anyone about the
polarized nature of political
campaigning in America Donald Trump's
supporters are pretty bedded in already
and when Radix like this and cases like
this even tend to come around those
supporters view them as an establishment
attack on somebody that they believe is
fighting for their rights they believe
that this man is the only person who's
going to speak up for them so I I tend
to think that actually in this
particular case it might work sadly in
his favor I mean that is an
extraordinary State of Affairs isn't it
Richard what other side of the political
divide you're on
this slew of cases now against Trump and
there are very serious other legal cases
which are rumbling through which might
lead to to further indictments it does
seem extraordinary that most of his
supporters don't seem to care about any
of it and his poll ratings seem to go up
right so the recent cases when he was
charged by The Establishment by the
authorities uh in New York actually his
poll ratings go up he gets more popular
and it's it's utterly counter-intuitive
and that's why we know what he'll do
with this we know how spin it he'll
appeal he'll fight and fight and fight
and he'll he'll he'll turn it to his
Advantage because that's what he does or
just to recap on that breaking news the
jury's return to verdict in the E Gene
Carroll Donald Trump battery rape and
defamation case the rule that Trump is
liable for sexual abuse and defamation
of Miss Carol but not of rape and he's
uh it's been awarded over two million
just under three million dollars in fact
so a
a loss really for Trump in totality
although he has been found not guilty of
the most serious charge and that should
be noted
um but a big breaking news development
in America will come back to that later
in the show well let's take a break
thank you very much indeed to my stellar
pack let's take a break uncensored next
following in Ronaldo's footsteps is
Lionel Messi risking his reputation by
becoming the latest footballer it's like
a huge contract in Saudi Arabia or
debate this next
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back Christian Ronaldo's Peter
even joining Saudi Arabia's al-nasa team
and the biggest money dealer football
history he'd sold out they said at worst
he trashed his legacy by Sports washing
the brutal Saudi regime Lionel Messi we
were sure would never do that and that
looks like Messi his closest rival and
the greatest of all time contest
although I think Ronaldo edges him will
be following him to the desert Kingdom
reports suggests the World Cup winner is
about to sign a 500 million pound deal
with the rival team Al hilal so are
these Legends Sports washing a brutal
regime or are they just banking the
bumper payday they deserve after
stunning careers and doing what many
footballers done going and playing in a
different country at the Twilight end of
their of their football lies I thought I
mean I was a boxing promoter Frank
Warren and by the human rights lawyer
and former managing director of these
United David Hager welcome to both of
you Frank it's a very emotive issue this
I remember when Ronaldo obviously I
remember it because I'd done the
interview which led to him going there
but
um I interviewed Cristiano that's why he
left United ends up going to Saudi
Arabia a lot of Messi fans mocking this
now probably having to eat their words
because looks like Messi may be
following Ronaldo because the money is
simply stratospherically higher than
these guys could get anywhere else in
the world at this stage in their careers
are they doing anything morally wrong
no I don't think so I think if you first
of all you've got to look at the
situation that you know last year our
elected government and the prime
minister is elected at the time Boris
Johnson if you remember when there was
all the oil prices were shooting up very
high he went over to Saudi to try and do
a deal for oil for us you know we have
companies over here in the UK who who
trade on a daily basis providing arms uh
uh airplanes cars everything to Saudi so
a sportsman who has a very short
lifespan or in his career you can't
blame them at the end of the day for
going there I don't you know it's a
question of their morals but and again
you look back you go back to the 60s I
can remember all the English players
going to South Africa and when the
apartheid was right on lots of them were
going now yeah well David hey my issue
with this whole Sports watching debate
and we had all this over the World Cup
in Qatar it's just this stinking
hypocrisy whichever way you look
everyone who puts on their moral Halo
including by the way our country which
last time I checked illegally invaded
Rock in 2003 what right do we have
frankly to cast moralist versions on
other countries and players taking their
business there given that we let them
play here when we did something like
that
well good evening Pez I mean I certainly
agree with you there is there is an
awful lot of Human Rights hypocrisy in
in football as well when you look at how
we deal with for instance Russian zoning
football clubs at the moment compared to
to to to golf dictatorships and you know
that's something that you see and you
know I agree with with Frank when he
says you can't blame people like Lionel
Messi for going to these countries but
as a human rights law of course I mean I
would want them to use the fact that
they are going there to help improve the
human rights records in those countries
and casts a a spotlight on the human
rights abuses of which there are many
but you don't think that people like
Ronaldo are Messi
um because of their Global Fame and
their two of the most followed people on
social media in the world Ronaldo's
number one and I think Messi's number
two on Instagram that just by going
there and living there and playing sport
there they cast an unbelievable light on
these countries we saw that with Qatar
and so in a way just by being there
these guys with their profile they do go
quite a long way to highlighting other
issues don't they
they do I mean that's that that's I
think one of the benefits that you get
from um players going to countries like
this and from the the what we saw in the
Qatar World Cup but I think that's a
smaller one you've also got I think look
at the fact that you know the people
that are being abused in Saudi and and
other countries you know and and how
they feel because at the end of the day
you know is we can debate this you know
it's Lionel Messi's football worth half
a billion for a couple of years that's
not a commercial decision in terms of a
football commercial decision it's
Edition by Saudi to effectively
sportswash their their human rights
abuses well actually you see I again I
take it I take issue with that because
you know I know a lot about the Ronaldo
deal and everything I I don't really
think that's what they're paying for
they're paying to grow football in Saudi
which we know from the Qatar World Cup
how well a lot of football in that
region is now going at teams like
Morocco and others they want to grow
Saudi football to make them proper World
players I really don't think that their
main reason for doing this and paying
these guys all this money money is to
sports wash their regime or to somehow
improve the world's view of their human
rights I think it's simply they want to
make
Saudi and other countries in the Middle
East
top of the world for putting on sport
I think it's you know it's it's
absolutely true I mean let me bring in
Frank yeah Frank you got you answered
that one
yeah sorry I you know I feel that's
right it's not just football I mean
they've they've invested very heavily in
golf Formula One WWE they've had boxing
now there is sports and it's all
reinvestment I mean to get someone to go
there you're going to have to pay them a
premium at this stage until it becomes a
destination and that's that's a fact of
life but there's for example the um
formula one has paid off hasn't it
they've done they've got they've got a
The Whole World's eyes are on that and
big boxing events and so forth yeah
right from a pure football point of view
Frank the cattle World Cup Saudi Arabia
beat the world champions Argentina in
the World Cup there was any team to do
so so there's no doubt that the quality
of football I know from Cristiano in in
Saudi he's been very impressed by the
general quality of the football there
and the fans are really fanatical and I
just again I come back to this this
issue I have with the hypocrisy once you
put morality at the center stage of
where people comply their trade in sport
well where do you end up going I mean
seriously where do you end up going I
mean David you're a gay man and you've
talked you've done a lot of good work in
that area in terms of LGBT rights and so
on I think you'll be something like a
quarter of all the teams in the World
Cup finals uh came from countries which
ban homosexuality for example do you not
have any tournaments in Africa for
example at all because of their record
in individual countries on gay rights in
other words it's complicated it's not as
easy as it may seem to people sitting
here in England
yeah no I agree with that I think like
as I said it's like you know you've got
considerable human rights hypocrisy and
and I don't think it's it's not possible
and it's perhaps not the right thing to
do to try and regulate individual
players going to you know for their
retirement whatever it may be to
whatever country you're never going to
be able to do that they'll be you know
there'll be more people doing it
there'll be more players but there are
areas in sports watching that we can
regulate and we saw recently with the
Premier League introducing uh what they
said would be new laws and new
regulations on the owners and directors
tests to Stamp Out dictators and despots
buying into English football I think
there's something that we can actually
try and improve the situation you know
should Nations like Saudi be able to buy
football you will have yeah to counter
that you will have people in the Middle
East who say that all the American
owners buying into the Premier League
well what's the difference they say they
are legally invaded Iraq like the UK did
they've done other stuff which they
believe abuses human rights as they
think the UK has as well it depends
where you are in the world as to how you
view these things you know when I was in
Canada
really struck by how angry they were
about all the hypocrisy about human
rights not to defend their own issues
they just say well who's who's actually
pointing the finger at us who's so
morally pure
I think that's the issue that you've got
and you know even you know how do you
judge and the football league uh the
sorry the Premier League in England have
said that they're gonna they're gonna
decide whether or not someone is a human
rights abuse on the basis of them being
on the our equivalent of the minitsky
sanction list and and then you look at
who's on it and there's effectively no
one that perhaps should be so you know
it's a very difficult thing to say who
is a human rights abuser and who isn't
who's the judge and jury of that so you
know whether you look at sports watching
in in terms of buying football clubs or
players going to these countries it's
very very difficult but one would hope
that people that have a platform you
know I had a platform that leads and I
try to improve you know um inclusivity
and diversity and and LGB rights and
football 10 years ago
um and one would hope but that's a
personal thing that people like Messi
and Ronaldo would use their platform to
do that and and you know that's that
that's that thing you'll never be able
to force them to do that or not
I was saying you also you look at the
demographic of Saudi Arabia I think it's
nearly 60 percent of the population are
under the age of 40. yeah so you've got
a younger generation there and the fact
these guys are going there they're
opening their eyes up to what is
happening and obviously you know as you
say Ronaldo Messi and many other people
are quite tolerant in their views and
and hopefully that will reflect in the
future I think that is a really
significant Point honestly I do I think
these guys aren't going to change their
views from what I've seen so far their
views are very well known they're all
shared on Instagram every day so the
fact they're over there shining a light
and it could work both ways actually
um Frank I can't let you go without
asking are we going to win the Premier
League Arsenal
oh God I'll tell you what I'm on the
edge that we we fell over on those three
three uh matches which uh I I I was like
torture but how impressive were they on
on they were brilliant but give me some
hopeless are we going to win Frank
I'm I'm I've got my I'm praying I'm from
everybody I've you know we've we all
want it to happen well man city got to
fall over haven't they for us they've
got to fall over they got they're going
to lose lose and draw one yeah that's a
big ass it's absolute agony isn't it uh
Frank great to see you David thank you
very much I appreciate it thanks guys
thanks peers on the center next to the
descendant Iranian who speaks up for
Russian sea for the women suppressed by
the brutal Islamic Republic timely
conversation after the debate we just
had
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
on the big breaking news from America in
the last few minutes Donald Trump former
president United States has been found
guilty of sexually abusing and defaming
aging Carol awarding her a total of five
million dollars against Trump in Damages
in a Civil Trial in New York the federal
jury found the former president not
guilty of rape
but they acknowledged that Trump had
abused her and had defamed her by
calling her a liar this followed an
incident in a Manhattan department store
nearly 30 years ago
well I'm joined Now by Randy zellen
who's a a lawyer from America
a criminal defense attorney So Randy
your reaction to this Breaking News
about Donald Trump
you can't spend this one I don't care
who you are that's like saying oh great
news great job I was convicted of I was
acquitted of Murder in the first degree
but convicted of murder in the second
degree spin it any way you want okay
great he didn't rape her he still
forcibly intentionally willfully
sexually abused her put her put his
hands on her and sexual parts he was
found liable and then the defamation
that's hey
you a lot about saying that this never
happened you said something that wasn't
true five million dollars may not mean
anything to him but reputation wise his
base may stay but everyone else headed
for the hills Donald Trump's issued a
statement on Truth social his social
media problem I've absolutely no idea
who this woman is his third is a
disgrace a continuation of the greatest
Witch Hunt of all time a predictable
response some might think uh from the
ex-president who tends to do this kind
of thing uh but what is the what is the
legal Jeopardy for him now facing all
these other uh legal issues that he's
facing does have any influence on that
at all
no I I think this is all baked in and
what will happen to him in terms of the
January 6th investigation in terms of
the Georgia trying to find the 11 000
votes in terms of the classified
documents whether he was found not
liable here or found liable that will
have no impact on the other criminal
investigations but what I find and what
resonates with me is exactly what you
were talking about previously you were
talking about hypocrisy and here the
hypocrisy is that if this jury had come
back in two hours and found him not
liable then this would have been the
greatest system in the world the
greatest jurors in the world I can do
whatever I want in New York the mere
fact that they came back with equally
stunning speed
and found against him it's a Witch Hunt
it's rigged and and that's the part to
me that at some level intelligent people
in this country have to start really
focusing in on
all right thank you very much thank you
for joining me I appreciate it
thank you well next tonight
it should be a progressive hero exiled
and hiding from Iran's assassin since
2009 she's a ferocious critic of the
Islamic Republic's brutality and its war
on women instead she's also on the
receiving end of criticism herself being
accused of his lava phobia for opposing
the compulsory hijab Iran has faced
massive protests this year after Manatee
police killed a 22 year old woman who
refused to wear one well she taught me
now so great to see you thank you so
much you're a hero to so many of us for
the way that you stood up to this we
talk a lot about human rights
there's very few places in the world
where there is a bigger assault on human
rights and women's rights than Iran
right now we just woke up with the news
of executions I mean there was a little
girl which I just published a video of
her on my Twitter account she was
begging the Islamic Republic officials
in Iran not to execute her father what
happened they did two young men got
executed for the crime of criticizing
Islam and Prophet Muhammad and then they
call me islamophobic come on
as a woman who grew up on their Sharia
law that showing my hair is a crime can
get me killed I deserve I mean I had the
right to be scared of sharia laws to be
scared of Islamic Republic and be honest
with you
phobia is irrational my fear and the
fear of millions of Iranian women women
of Afghanistan of Taliban and Islamic
Republic is rational I'm just saying the
same thing in Afghanistan where that
overnight shameful overnight
fleeing by led by America from
Afghanistan under President Biden led to
total chaos a lot of death but also
basically through millions of Afghan
women back to the Taliban wolves and
we're seeing the same thing there my
heart is broken because I see that now
uh the news about women of Afghanistan
being Fade Out the news about the women
LED revolution in Iran being Fade Out
and people think that everything is over
but women are in front line and chanting
woman life Freedom they want to
overthrow agenda apartheid regime I was
actually talking uh to people here in
the UK and I wanted to get the public
opinion the attention of British women
and men that think about it a day that
women are being kicked out from a
stadium women get uh killed for showing
their hair getting arrested and raped
for singing for dancing what would be
the reaction of the rest of the world I
mean if it was not women of Iran if it
was not women of uh the Middle East
women in the UK get kicked out from a
stadium what would you do what would
FIFA do you know that it's a gender
apartheid regime completely you know
that by saying all this you're putting a
bigger Target on your back all the time
do you worry about that I mean to be
honest as you hear me I'm very loud
against a terrorist I'm not as scared of
them but let's be very honest it's a
scary when you see a man with loaded gun
in front of your house trying to kill
you the Islamic Republic hired three
Russian mafia
and they were trying to kill me on U.S
soil the FBI arrested them right now
they are in prison but it's a scary but
at the same time I'm not carrying any
weapon I'm only 45 kilos that actually
shows you that the Islamic Republic they
are scared of me and millions of women
like I think they are yeah I think they
are and I feel the Iranian women they're
beginning to realize their own power
perhaps collectively yes I mean Iranian
women they are my heroes thank you so
much for calling me hero but my heroes
are in Iran actually they know that
they're facing guns and bullets some of
them get shot in their eyes they're
blinded but they say that you can take
our life you can take our eyes you can
take our bodies but not our hope we are
here to end this what more should the
West be doing Sydney maybe Western women
that's a good question that's a very
good question and that's why I am here
to meet with the members of parliament
here in London and inform them about
what's going on in Iran it's not about
us trying to just save ourselves the
Islamic Republic is a threat to
democracy and we are actually risking
our life to protect democracy across the
globe and I'm not just claiming that
right now the Islamic Republic sending
drones to Putin to kill innocent
ukrainians how ironic that the woke left
attack you I mean this has been my issue
with them about women's rights generally
they're on the wrong side of history
with all this stuff I mean I still have
hope that I can actually convince them
that this is the right time that you
have to support us because look the
Islamic Republic actually hired Killers
here to kill a journalists from your you
know the Iran International biggest TV
Persian TV broadcasting here they were
to Target of the Islamic Republic so you
see if you don't support our fight
against Islamic Republic you have to
face the terrorists on Western soil so
clearly what happened in Vegas it says
that it's gonna stay in Vegas but what
happened in the Middle East in Iran it's
not going to stay there it's going to
infect the rest of the world here in the
UK they're being paid by euchar
government uh having Islamic Center for
what let me be very clear with you
British people are like British weather
they're not predictable but the Islamic
Republic officials they are predictable
they are here not to express them
themselves they are here to expand their
ideology to uh you know to sponsor
terrorist organization and they are here
to kill innocent Iranians that's why I'm
asking the UK government I hope I can
meet with the UK prime minister yeah
maybe the king to convince them that
this is the time that my people are
risking their lives to protect democracy
you're an incredibly courageous Lady
it's great to have you in here your
passion Rings through and your courage
Rings through I hope people are
listening and watching it thank you I
appreciate it I hope one day I'm going
to invite you to my beautiful
I would love that I know it's a
beautiful country thank you so much it's
good to see you thank you very much
indeed pleasure I promise that's what
courage looks like and that's why
women's rights are important well
uncensored next the US Navy Seals
appointed drag queen as a recruitment
Ambassador cure rather strong reaction
from perhaps the most famous Navy Seal
of all the man who killed Osama Bin
Laden who joins me next
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
Christmas
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel nobody use
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
while coming up on the talk in that
breaking news a jury has found Donald
Trump sexually abused the writer E.G and
Carroll and it's claim that Boris
Johnson clashed with King Charles over
interfering in politics and the
Metropolitan Police says a criminal
network of people posing as stewards did
plan to derail the coronation all that
with this lot at nine
[Music]
welcome back HC appointment no one saw
coming yeoman's second class Joshua
Kelly also known as drag queen Harvey
Daniels announced on Tick Tock he would
be a digital ambassador to the U.S Navy
Seals he was one of several diverse
faces chosen to reach a wide range of
potential candidates Navy said there's a
seeks to recruit more gen Z service men
and service women and apparently service
them well I'm joined from New York I
form a U.S Navy SEAL Robert Neal the man
of course who killed Osama Bin Laden on
that incredible raid Rob I did think of
you the moment I heard about this story
as to what on Earth you would make of
this new recruitment Drive
by your old people I mean what what is
going on here
well thanks for having me Paris I don't
know what's going on here it's for some
reason they like to go woke a lot excuse
me a lot of different places and uh the
woke move is not working at all I'm all
about freedom and people want to do what
they want do it behind closed doors even
out to see if the guys want to have a
drag show my first question would be
where's the chief's mess and who made
this decision but if they want to do it
you know what goes on and see stays at
Sea however using for an enlisted sailor
enlisted Soldier should not be famous in
the first place you shouldn't really be
on social media certainly certainly not
be advertising for the Navy on a Chinese
Espionage site which is Tick Tock
um and what we're supposed to be doing
is is projecting Alliance solidarity's
forward defense and deterrence and to
have a drag queen uh that's not going to
deter the Chinese who are actually
trying to globally take over and to me
this is just part of a a long-standing
scheme that goes way back to the USSR
where uh they're trying to demoralize
our uh make the make make make something
not normal just so that we think it's
normal and then they can also Robert
does this follows the course of fiori
over the Bud Light campaign using Dylan
Mulvaney the the the trans influencer uh
who until very recently identified as
male again massive backlash against Bud
Light in fact I think sales down 25 or
something you can't help thinking this
will have the exact opposite effect that
the Navy hope it will why would people
watch this the right people for the Navy
Seals and think that's what I want to
join I don't get it they won't but Bud
Light didn't realize who Their audience
was and again not that there's anything
wrong with what's going on but you're
going to lose your audience and the the
people who aren't being heard right here
are the men and women who are now
serving in the military and the young
men and women who might potentially join
that maybe won't because of stuff like
this it's it's the there's a there's a
cut off in leadership where they're
making a decision based on what a
politician wants them to make so they
can get a job later and the politician's
happy and uh the news media for the
majority won't cover it because it's not
the the woke leftist thing to do I mean
like I said I'm all about Freedom do
what you want but we need the the
military is not there for a lot of this
command climate how how are you feeling
today nonsense it's supposed to be be
are You Ready for War today because you
should be and when we need to go we go
and then all the other nonsense which
comes with after the war is down to the
diplomats they're using the military for
the wrong reasons this is the wrong way
to recruit and I I talk to people in the
military I travel the country I travel
the world and I it's not just scientific
polls that I listen to I'm getting the
pulse of the people on the majority of
people don't want this for that reason
not that there's not a place for it this
certainly isn't it you know we began
this show you may not have seen this but
we got this show because the the labor
party leader here who's tipped to be the
next prime minister the way the polls
are going has has announced that he
doesn't think the public care about woke
issues this is the kind of thing that
I'm talking about when I say they
absolutely do because I can't imagine
many people watching this to night I'm
not going to watch this story and think
this is wokery gone completely bonkers
yeah it certainly is the there's like I
said there's a time and place for
everything but even with like liberal
issues they're being hijacked by
leftists because they're going so far to
the left that it doesn't even make sense
anymore it's it's uh it becomes so
partisan that they're they're making
decisions that that don't need to be
made they're they're one of the things
they're doing is they're talking
themselves into losing as opposed to
just sometimes the simplest answer is
right in front of your face there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with
making a simple answer and the simple
answer the way to recruit young men
especially in this country is with the
United States Marine and a flaming sword
fighting the dragon that's the people
you want in the military I mean not that
we don't want everyone and again I don't
want to be I don't want to be you know
exclude anybody but when we took 23 of
the most highly qualified men on the
mission to kill Bin Laden not one of us
cared what the other sexual identity was
we cared if they're are there guns
loaded are their batteries fresh and if
I get shot can you carry me back to my
family that's that's all we care about
we're keeping it simple not not what do
you do on the weekend to entertain
yourself behind closed doors it doesn't
matter it's not important stop making it
an issue yeah it's just are you good
enough right are you good enough to do
your job and potentially save the people
you're with from getting killed I mean
that seems to me to be the criteria to
be a Navy SEAL hey I know that's the
reason I got picked it wasn't because I
was the smartest guy in the room I just
happened you could point me in the right
direction tell me who the bad guy is and
hopefully I shoot the right person I was
smart enough to do that we can leave the
other stuff to other people but uh do
your job do it right and then come home
you know I'll still give you the other
night I was watching 0.30 of course
about the bin Laden raid and then a week
early I'll watch Captain Phillips and I
also watched with my son's Lone Survivor
and I suddenly remembered that you were
on all three of those missions I watched
those movies you know and enjoy them as
entertainment what the hell is it like
for you to watch these movies when you
were actually on all of them Lone
Survivor was actually on today just an
hour ago when I was watching part of it
a great movie great acting the only
complaint is they couldn't find
mountains that were actually steep
enough for the actor to jump off of what
these these Heroes actually did and uh
you can't explain the heat that's there
and what it's like to have an enemy
trying to kill you and then Captain
Phillips you know leaving your
daughter's classroom on your birthday
jumping into the Indian Ocean 16 hours
later than rescuing Richard Phillips on
each on Easter Sunday and then uh you
know Zero Dark Thirty that's just proof
that there's one big team the woman that
found Bin Laden was a woman an actual
tough woman that found Bin Laden if you
want to recruit use her if you want to
get a real a really an awesome female
operator watch that movie try to be like
Maya the characters great movies all um
they they didn't have there wasn't
enough time to tell all the stories but
yeah it is funny though I'm just proof
that uh wherever you are be there and
anything can happen in your life did you
ever meet that that lady Maya for the
zero the real one
yeah I met her I'm um I met her the
first day she was one that said the
reason you're here is because this is as
close as we've ever been to Osama Bin
Laden we did the mission I saw her a few
months later in a bar in New York over a
beer and I said hey how was all the
blowback and she said I didn't even get
a parking spot
you guys real heroes Rob it's great to
talk to you uh thank you so much I the
old phrase go woke go broke at some
point they're going to realize it's
actually true
at some point they're going to prove
themselves right yeah exactly Rob great
to see you all the best thank you
anytime that's it from us tonight what
are you up to Keep It Uncensored I'm
sure Rob O'Neill does that's it good
night
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember